you can expect a big push from President
Trump tonight for his border wall even
though Congress has not yet approved
funding for it national correspondent
William la jeunesse tells us work on
prototypes is well underway San Diego
before offense and after apprehensions
down 95 percent according to the border
patrol Yuma before offense and after
illegal traffic down 90 percent that's
Mexico and then on the other side you
have a secondary fence call it a wall or
a fence critics claim they don't work
but those who actually work here say
they do the reduced the amount of
traffic the flow migration and drugs it
was coming across the border the
evidence shows that barriers work
homeland security teams took jack
hammers saws and torches to the latest
prototypes when you walk up to those
prototypes and you see a 25 to 30 foot
wall it's daunting tactical teams try
climbing the walls only one made it to
the top but couldn't get down will they
scale it will they tunnel under it yes
but you discourage as much as you can on
the onset you're dealing with a smaller
portion that you now have to push
technology manpower and other assets at
based on topography need and budget each
border sector will extend an existing
fence replace an old fence or add a
secondary wall allowing agents to
apprehend immigrants in an enforcement
zone I don't think Democrats are saying
no to a wall no to physical
infrastructure what we're what Democrats
are saying is let's be smart about it so
far based on testing many agents prefer
the bollard style fence with the anti
scaling concrete panel on top why one
they can see through it two agents say
an illegal immigrant can jump that
primary fence and cut through the
existing secondary fence in less than
two minutes
Bret William thank you